Haylee beaver says Miley Cyrus used to
bully her ganging up on her with older
sister Alya and being quote evil I'm
shocked Miley the little lover
anyway this all went down during an
episode of carpool karaoke while the 22
year old model and her bestie kendall
Jenner jammed out two hit songs in the
car and when party in the u.s. they came
on the two were surprised by Miley
herself no literally so be evil to her
she would try to play with us like me
and Alya and then we would like lock her
out of the room you know it made you
stronger it did now you can always take
the lake trolls and such a troll
I missed the biggest try wasn't roll she
prepared stories so you'd be like a lion
Miley would gang up on me I'm a big
sister so I can kind of relate I was
horrible to my little sister she's my
best friend but yeah yeah I'm also a big
sister and I wasn't mean to my little
sister can't relate but I will say that
the trolling part I kind of get where
Miley is coming from we're prepared you
for fame but like let the fans do that
let the actual trolls do that I don't
know if I'd take credit for this one
Haley took to her Instagram stories over
the weekend to explain the impact that
these online haters have had on her
writing in part quote it's hard to focus
on your well-being and mental health
when each time you open Instagram
someone is tearing apart your job or
your relationship or essentially any of
the things in your life that are
positive we need to express more love
and encouragement to one another instead
of consistently tearing people down and
judging I won't let people make me feel
like I'm doing something wrong
by enjoying my life and being happy
aa-men Haley Prix seriously I really
loved that perspective I feel like more
people need to be on board with that but
of course Miley wasn't the only surprise
that came her way during that episode
Haley who quietly Wed husband Justin
Bieber in a New York City courthouse in
September looked a little bit nervous
when she found out that her and Kendall
would
have lie-detector tests done on the ho
who do you prefer more can record me at
the moment Courtney true okay
have you ever created a fake Instagram
to look at what your ex-boyfriend is
doing if you could block Connie on
Twitter without him knowing would you
know um not true
I want to see the crazy he says does
Justin think I'm cool of course that's a
lie
carpool karaoke lie-detector test could
be a whole spin-off series I'm here for
that one knee - lets get that trending
o'malley we need to help ok guys I met
Courtney underscore Tasman oh and I met
Halle underscore Stephen bye for now